here at cbs news we are committed we've
talked about this several times to
stopping the stigma
surrounding mental health so we would
like to take the shame and the blame out
of discussing mental illnesses
kim kardashian west is pretty much
asking for the same thing she's asking
for compassion
and empathy after unusual comments made
by her husband kanye west on twitter
at a recent event in a statement posted
on instagram yesterday
kim kardashian west talked about how her
husband lives with bipolar disorder
she wrote in part quote anyone who has
this or has a loved one in their life
who does knows how incredibly
complicated
and painful it is to understand
psychiatrist dr
sue varma joins us now we should note
that dr sue varma does not treat kanye
west and has not spoken to the family
so she cannot speak directly about his
condition and
actually see that's not what this
conversation is about it really is about
bringing attention to this because i
thought what kim did was
very brave and i think that it will be
very helpful to others that she was so
candid
about what her family's going through
absolutely and you know we have talked
about on this show the idea of
celebrities coming forward and what it
does is mainstream and normalize the
conversation
and i want to say that it doesn't matter
what kind of resources you have
struggle is still struggle and the
family members still feel
helpless and one of the hardest things
about bipolar disorder which is fairly
common
it's about one percent of the population
but gail i really think that it goes
under-diagnosed for a lot of reasons and
because
in some of these symptoms when a person
presents they might only present with
one aspect of it
in bipolar disorder we see a gamut of
symptoms ranging from irritability
low mood guilt feelings of worthlessness
to high moods to where a person might be
extremely high functioning and creative
to symptoms of paranoia and disorganized
thinking
so depending on when you come in you may
miss some of these other symptoms and
not get diagnosed
so sue what is it exactly and what is it
that you think we most don't understand
about it
i think it's the unpredictability it's
hard for doctors to recognize because
when you go into a primary care visit or
even a trained mental health
professional
they're seeing you at one snapshot in
time and what they really need to do is
take a longitudinal history and
ask family members and ask them does
this person have
difficulty falling asleep or do they are
they are able to function on very little
sleep
do they make a lot of impulsive plans do
they plan to like you know go from one
city to another are they going to vegas
when you know we have that freedom are
they buying shirts in five different
colors
again these are very stereotypical
things but are important to ask because
they often get
missed the impairment in functioning is
very severe
people don't realize that bipolar
disorder often and a lot of mental
health conditions
when they're not treated become chronic
and even though i'm
very much of the belief of holistic
lifestyle intervention such as talk
therapy exercise nutrition
there really is a role of medication in
this and a person may not
need may need to be on it for an
extended period of time and that can be
hard for a person to swallow
especially when they're in the midst of
a manic episode or a depression
they might be feeling paranoid and they
think that maybe someone's poisoned them
maybe they don't
someone is out to get them so the
hardest thing about this is that a
patient's own
insight and awareness and judgment are
affected by the illness
you know a lot of the chatter around it
was why don't people get help why don't
family members get help why don't people
intervene
and in her letter kim pointed out you
know that's very difficult unless the
individuals themselves
want to engage in the process of getting
help so what can family members do
what can loved ones do in situations
like these
you know be very involved in the
person's life
be vigilant get educated about it
if and when they're willing because
there might be narrow windows of
opportunity where somebody may say
i don't feel well can you help me they
may not even ask for your help but they
might just appreciate your support so
i'm a big believer in family therapy
it's something i do in my practice
and even if i'm just treating the
individual i will try to engage the
family time to time
the family members must be involved you
know look it takes a village to raise
any person a healthy person a sp but
especially someone who's dealing with a
condition or a disorder we really need
to rally against the person
what makes it hard is because often some
of these behaviors because they're
erratic
family members might feel alienated they
might feel pushed away
they might feel scared by the behavior
it's unpredictable they don't know what
to expect
a person might lash out and be angry at
them so i would say if you can
understand this as a brain illness
not take it personally and say listen
in what capacity can i be helpful do you
want me to drive you to your doctor's
appointment do you want me to find you a
doctor i'll wait in the parking lot i
don't need to be a part of it
but if they're open to and if they give
you permission
try to have a conversation if you're a
close family member to say let me
understand
what are the symptoms and how can i help
them what are the medications what are
the side effects
side effects of medication are a big
reason why people get off of
a get off of them and then relapse
yeah i think what you said sue was very
important think of this as a brain
illness
i mean in in our ongoing effort to
reduce the stigma and the shame
what's the best thing you can say about
that part of this conversation
this needs to be taken very seriously in
the pandemic
all of us are experiencing heightened
stress you are not alone
please don't feel isolated there is
absolutely no shame
no stigma you're not less of a person
you didn't cause this to yourself
please get help help is available take
your time do your due diligence find a
trusted person
and give the treatment some time it
always takes time to work
all right dr sue varma always good to
see you thank you very much
if you or someone you know is seeking
mental health resources you can call the
national alliance on mental illness
helpline
that number is 1-800-950-6264
i know it's hard to write it down
quickly so we'll have it on our website
or in a crisis you can text nami to
741-741